breaking news tonight we're going to
cover a huge and a damning development
from the deep state it's leading oh
right into the office of the Special
Counsel robert muller to the rise of the
radical up we'll get into all of this
tonight we begin though with our Hannity
watch tonight on the flagrant hypocrisy
double standard Democrats in the
Commonwealth of Virginia Democrat
governor Ralph Northam
has now embarrassed himself and the
state that he calls home now as you know
he first openly supported oh infanticide
well first the baby will be born and
then of course we'll make sure the baby
is comfortable and then after the baby
is comfortable the mother will decide
well whether to resuscitate them we'll
all have a little conversation but he
represents yet another chapter in his
party's long disgraceful history now on
the issue of race and meanwhile as
lieutenant governor Democrat Justin
Fairfax who Democrats want to replace
the current governor he tonight is
facing very serious accusations of
sexual misconduct now the Democrats are
now facing their very own serious me to
issue the Commonwealth of Virginia has
descended into total chaos and turmoil
tonight will the Democrats now declare I
believe all victims we're going to
address that question in a few minutes
now to remind you on Friday that
extremely disturbing 1984 yearbook photo
from Eastern Virginia Medical School
surfaced showing a man dressed in
blackface next to a person that's
wearing a Ku Klux Klan uniform and as
you can see the photo appeared under
Ralph Northam 's name along with other
photos of the 25 year old medical
student and shortly thereafter another
yearbook photo surfaced this one from
BMI which listed a racist and
extraordinarily offensive word as
Northam snick name and then last Friday
Governor Northam he began the apology
tour tried to apologize for appearing in
the racist Medical College photo but
over the weekend then he changed his
mind and he said that he wasn't actually
in the photo that appeared under his
name in his yearbook than any admitted
that he did in fact wear blackface and
in the very same year but that was at
another event as this gets more and more
bizarre by the minute watch this
I reflect it with my family and
classmates from the time and affirm to
my conclusion that I am not the person
in that photo that same year I did
participate in a dance contest in San
Antonio in which I darken my face is
part of a Michael Jackson costume
I had the shoes I had a glove and I used
us a little bit of shoe polish to put
under my are all my cheeks and the
reason I used a very little bit is
because I don't know if anybody's ever
tried that but you cannot get shoe
polish off okay black shoe polish which
he knew was hard to get off and off his
face before he dressed up like Michael
Jackson
okay you think you can't get worse
believe it or not it got even more
bizarre and what has been described as
beyond surreal and such a Cavalier
moment for Northam he actually consider
performing Michael Jackson's Moonwalker
dance right there during the press
conference well that was until his wife
stepped in take a look he said the
competition in San Antonio was a dance
comfort - yes and it was that you danced
the moonwalk that's right are you still
able to moonwalk my wife says in
appropriate circumstances oh my wife
thank goodness his wife was there does
this really look like a man who's taking
that issue seriously and let's not
forget this is only a few days after
Northam actually defended the
infanticide issue and of course Northam
is now refusing to step down we sent our
own Sarah Carter to the Commonwealth of
Virginia earlier today to see what
Northam skin' stitch ooh ins think about
this ongoing scandal let's take a look
when you look at this photograph on
governor nor thumbs yearbook page what
goes through your mind
makes me uncomfortable more than
anything not okay it just shows that
this is the character of a man point
blank I don't care about the car I don't
care about his nice picture just this is
who he was the only thing I see that
he's done wrong is not admitting it's
him it's his what is his page in his
yearbook but other than that it's 35
years ago he was a young man eat that
stupid stuff like a lot of us did do you
feel that him going back and forth first
it was him it was him like you wouldn't
I don't care if he oh I haven't seen
this yearbook if that was it
I think it bothers me that he's not
being honest I think if he owns up to it
maybe more people would be a little more
graceful towards it and understanding
for both sides of the parties and what
do you think should happen next
he should suck it up resign whether he
should resign that's up to him entirely
I'm not going to tell him what to do I
hope he's better person now that
understands this is not okay but the
fact that he did it at all is it just
makes me not feel good about him how can
you do that how can you spit in the
faces of people that that trusted you so
it is disturbing it's very disturbing
and you and you'd like to see him resign
and yes I would and I voted for him as
of today many Democrats have called on
Northam to resign but he was once
endorsed by all of his party's key
political players including let's see
senators Mark Warner Tim Kaine Clinton
hack Terry McAuliffe the former governor
and even President Obama who claimed
that Northam would put an end to
divisive politics now instead north and
ran on a race baiting platform his motto
was we're welcoming in inclusive Donald
Trump is divisive and dangerous ok
Northam is far from the only Democrat by
the way to run this type of campaign
which brings us to tonight's Hannity
history lesson that is the Democratic
Party's racist past clearly not that
long ago
many Republicans we're proud to be well
I'm actually conservative but the party
of Lincoln the Emancipation Proclamation
the 1960 civil rights movement and
Democrats well they don't want you to
know anything about their past for
example
112 Democratic lawmakers voted against
the 1964 Civil Rights Act which outlawed
racism against minorities which by the
way Lyndon Johnson needed the Republican
Party Al Gore's father prominent
Democrat well as a senator he voted
against the Civil Rights Act one year
later 70 Democrats voted against the
1965 Voting Rights Act which prevented
racism at the ballot box
and the Democratic Party also largely
opposed racial integration in schools in
1959 99 Democratic lawmakers signed off
what was known as the southern manifesto
which was drafted to counter the
historic Brown v Board of Education
Supreme Court decision and his governor
Oh Democrat George Wallace he stood in
the doorway of a Birmingham school to
physically block racial integration
former President Bill Clinton yes call J
William Fulbright so many times his his
great mentor Fulbright vigorously
opposed all integration efforts and
Clinton's beloved mentor was a
segregationist meanwhile Hillary Clinton
said that Senator Robert KKK bird
because was her mentor Byrd was a
lifelong Democrat before serving in
Congress yeah Byrd was actually in the
Ku Klux Klan in the Senate bird actually
filibustered the 64 Civil Rights Act for
14 hours later apologized for his racist
past KKK ties but in 2001 Hillary
Clinton's mentor sparked even more
controversy over these racist comments
this was during an interview with our
friend Tony snow take a look there are
white I've seen not a white night I'm
gonna use that word but we've all we
just need to work together to make our
country a better contract and the
Hannity history lesson continues
meanwhile we have another prominent
Democrat Oh crazy Uncle Joe former Vice
President Joe Biden also facing charges
of racism according to the Washington
Times 1975 opposed the policy called
desegregation busing which helped
integrate public schools of course this
shouldn't surprise anyone
kind of crazy Uncle Joe has a long
history make it really dumb well I'll
let you decide what kind of remarks take
a look in Delaware the largest growth of
population is Indian Americans moving
from India you cannot go to unless you
have a slight Indian accent what kind of
a chance with a northeastern liberal
like Joe Biden stand in the South better
than anybody else you don't know my
state my state was a slave state my
state is a border state my state is the
eighth largest black population in the
country we've got the first
[Music]
clean nice looking guy
unchain Wall Street
you're gonna put y'all back in Chains
first african-american art ick EULA
bright and clean and of course my
state's a slave state then of course you
can't go to a 7-eleven or a Dunkin
Donuts let's have a slight Indian accent
imagine any Trump supporter said this
now deflection is the name of the game
of course and lying a distortion of the
Democratic Party and the hard left in
this country I tell you every two and
four years the party actively avoids
their racist past and claims the
Republicans racist sexist homophobic
xenophobic Islamophobic dirty air water
killed children and granny I guess it
shouldn't surprise anyone at the party
of Robert Byrd George Wallace Al Gore's
senior now is using this race issue as a
political ploy yet again take a look
many Republicans talking coded racial
language about takers and losers they
demonize President Obama and encourage
the ugliest impulses of the paranoid
fringe if you accept the support of Klan
sympathizers before you are president
you will accept their support after your
presence it's wrong what the leader of
the Republican Party and this Congress
are doing in blocking an accurate census
because they don't want to count
everyone that they don't think they can
count on they are in favor of
affirmative action if you can dunk the
basketball or sink a three-point shot
but they're not in favor of it if you
merely have the potential to be a leader
in your community and bring people
together don't tell me we've got a
colorblind society you let another
Church explode when you don't vote you
allow another cross to burn now sadly in
addition to race Democrats are also
actively exploiting the me2 movement for
political gain we saw a prime example
recently during the Kavanagh
confirmation process
Democrats using uncorroborated
unsubstantiated claims a past sexual
misconduct going back to high school
remember including untrue wild
accusations of nearly weekly gang rapes
and drugging young girls why to oppose
Cavanaugh's confirmation they said all
women are to be believed no one gets due
process no one gets the presumption of
innocence guilty as charged
remember this I'd only do women like dr.
Ford who bravely comes forward need to
be heard but they need to be believed
they need to be believed I just want to
say to the men in this country just shut
up and step up do the right thing let me
just say right at the outset I believe
dr. Ford I believe the survivor here I
believe her I stand with her she should
be bullied into
this scenario I believe her I believe
professor Ford I think she's credible
uh-oh Democrats now have a very serious
meat to problem themselves I want to see
how many of those very same Democrats
will now say I believe why the
lieutenant governor of Virginia just in
Fairfax who many Democrats want to
replace Northam if he resigns
well he's facing tonight a serious
charge of serious sexual misconduct
earlier today he finally responded
called the encounter consensual now
we're gonna be consistent we're not
gonna rush to judgment we never do
due process presumption of innocence
even avenatti remember those charges we
waited the very thing he didn't give
judge Kavanaugh turns out he was cleared
of those allegations that's not the
standard though of the Democratic Party
I believe without any real evidence any
even hearing from somebody aren't all
claims supposed to now be believed first
isn't this now a disqualifier for office
for the lieutenant governor our
Democrats now going to call for the
lieutenant governor of the Commonwealth
of Virginia to resign I'm not holding my
breath you're now going to watch a
looming double standard pure hypocrisy
play out in real time by the way where's
Kamala Harris tonight
where's Gillibrand Blumenthal Feinstein
their silence is deafening pure utter
hypocrisy the same people that
bludgeoned justice Cavanaugh smeared
slandered besmirched him just like many
did Clarence Thomas of Robert Bork Sarah
Carter also asked Virginians about this
looming scandal and the Democrats double
standard let's take a look the business
with Fairfax I I haven't seen anything
to substantiate the initial claim so I
need more evidence
I have such like a strong opinion on
like sexual assault and stuff like that
and so I think it's really upsetting but
I don't think that he'll get like as
much attention about it as like
Cavanaugh dead and why do you think that
is because he's a Democrat I think you
need
- instead of jumping into a story and a
piece of information the information
should be given reviewed is it
legitimate is it not legitimate and then
you go from there
they believe now we'll have more later
in the program now we need to turn our
Hannity watch to the hate Trump media
tonight we can report attorneys for
Covington Catholic student Nick Sandman
are prepared now to file suit after he
and his classmates were falsely accused
of harassing tribal elder nathan
phillips last month in washington DC
these were smears and that led to death
threats online abuse even temporarily
they had to close their northern
kentucky school in an exclusive
statement tonight right here - Hannity
this program famed defamation attorney
Linwood who is now representing salmon
says quote an agenda driven mob trampled
on Knicks reputation and permanently
damaged him now nick has no choice
except to fight back against the lies
the threats his weapon of choice is the
truth remember we told you on this
program night after night don't rush to
judgment and we were proven right yet
again as the media Hollywood slander
libel tried to destroy this teenager as
the facts came out we saw a very
different story that Nick stood there
calmly peacefully and it was Phillips
who approached him and also remember it
was this group of black Hebrew
Israelites verbally abusing those
Covington students like calling them
future school shooters and that's among
the nice things they said
now so far Sandman's legal team has sent
at least 50 letters to media outlets
politicians Hollywood celebrities and
even Catholic organizations warning them
all of potential legal action the list
does include the New York Times actors
Jim Carrey Alyssa Milano 2020 candidate
Elizabeth Warren the Archdiocese of
Louisville and Baltimore and remember
Linwood oh he was Richard Jules attorney
I knew him in Atlanta remember Richard
Jewell falsely accused perpetrating the
Olympic bombing well that's where I met
Linwood an amazing attorney an
incredible track record of success in
these types of cases
I would expect that justice will be
served well more on that story all right
we have a major development today as to
Robert Muller's pit bull Andrew Weissman
Catherine Herridge will join us later in
the program we'll talk more about that
the dirty dossier and going right into
the office of the Special Counsel in
other words Hillary Clinton that dirty
dossier